being a writer actually requires a
number of different skills and when
you're not good at one of the skills it
can make you think you're not good at
any of them and that is one of the
reasons that hamster brain occurs so one
thing is simply the use of language if
English is not your first language or
you tend to write awkwardly sometimes
you think you're not a good writer
because your word choice is bad but
that's one skill that you can work on
like literally like a dictionary skill
like choosing great vocabulary and
choosing great imagery right that's one
skill second skill is taking a character
through a journey it's actually
understanding the psychology of people
and understanding if I'm I think I'm
ugly how do I walk through the world how
does a character overcome the belief
that I'm ugly right and that's actually
an understanding of people and
understanding of psychology and you want
to let know that so you can create
characters that are deep and interesting
and you want to be a great observer of
your friends of your parents of your of
all the people who annoy you right so
that you can document a document who
they are but also understand them from
an interesting perspective that's a
different skill then there's another
skill which is especially for filmmaking
is being able to show not tell being
able to ground all of your scenes in
moments that are visual that extent that
give all the information you want to
give but don't don't have it let me tell
you and then this happened and then this
happened and then this happened and then
this happened right and the last one
which is probably the most important one
and very difficult for people to do is
to really speak from your authentic
voice and we we we want so much as
writers to be seen and to be heard and
we know that we have something
say and that desire that longing can
pull us out of ourselves and and when
you get pulled out of yourself then
you're trying to imitate breaking back
you're trying to imitate scandal you're
trying to imitate some movie that you
love and you've lost your sense of what
it is you're bringing to the world what
you've seen in the world so finding that
authentic voice and saying what I know
is valuable what I see is valuable the
way I'm going to show it as valuable is
a skill in itself and it's the practice
of actually affirming your unique vision
like being able to go into a Starbucks
even and saying the way I order my
Starbucks the way I like my Maya pasta
the way I like to cross the street the
way I like to drive is unique and
valuable and the more you anchor into
the sense of your own value and the
importance of your voice in the world
the more powerful that voice is going to
be because the other things I described
are literally like techniques that you
can practice but this other technique of
actually affirming your own authentic
voice is probably the most important one
you